It's me, Drew.
(Ross laughs)
(Drew laughs)
In case you couldn't tell.
(Ross laughs)
Ross and I, at the commercial break,
he keeps staring at me.
I go, "You do Drag Race, what?
Yeah, but this is like a Drag Race
level of transformation.
It's pretty wild.
And you look so good, Drew.
Thank you, Rossi.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
All right, what's next, Rossi?
All right, well, we talked about Emily in Paris.
I'm obsessed, anybody else watch that show?
Yes, I love it!
Yes, it's so good.
It's breaking records on Netflix.
And while filming it in Paris on location,
sounds like it would be so glamorous,
Insider reports, that star Lily Collins,
said it was a real pain in the foot
because during filming she had to see a podiatrist
every single week,
'cause her dogs were a barking.
(audience laughs)
Apparently cobble stones and stilettos don't mix.
Yeah, has anyone here had kids?
(audience cheers)
Your feet are never the same.
After the kids?
Oh my God, first of all,
my foot grew three shoe sizes.
No!
Three, I went from a six to a nine
and I went back down to like a seven, 7.5.
My whole shoe collection's gone.
Really?
Yeah, I had to give it all away or donated it.
Well, do they hurt, heels?
I, believe it or not, don't wear 'em.
(audience laughs)
I did a Western movie.
Did you say it like that whenever you say?
A Western, I did.
And I always will.
And I had to wear real corsets.
Oof.
But I was like 17.
So it was totally different.
Whereas now I would rather eat glass
than wear a corset.
Yeah.
Another thing that happens after children
you're just like, "It's not worth it."
(Ross chuckles)
I'm looking at you right now.
You don't need a corset, okay?
Thank you.
Look at her, hello!
(audience cheers)
Next!
This, this, this!
We all turn to friends for relationship advice.
Yes.
But experts say their advice is possibly bad.
Pop Sugar reports that according to a dating app survey,
54% of gen Z singles regret taking their friends advice.
Mm-hmm.
Experts say your friend's advice is questionable at best
because number one, they can be projecting
their own relationship stuff onto you,
which may not be for you.
And number two, you might have different
wants, needs and desires for a relationship
that maybe they can't understand, Ross thoughts?
Well, that's a really nice way to say
maybe your friend is a mess
and you shouldn't listen to them.
I think, right?
(audience claps)
It depends on the friend.
We all have the friends
who you go to for advice about relationships.
And then we have the friends
you go to for advice about tequila.
There's different areas of expertise.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪